Salut, on est samedi matin, il est beaucoup trop tôt
et on va attaquer le 3ème Master Class'
Il faut que je vous dise quelque chose, il faut que je le partage avec vous
Ce Master Class' je l'ai filmé, là déjà, il y a une heure en fait
Je l'ai écrit, je l'ai tourné, je l'ai filmé en double caméra et j'ai eu un problème de vidéo.
J'ai perdu tout les rushs avant même de les monter
J'ai failli arrêter le MentalVlog de cette déception
On s'en fiche, c'est le 3ème Master Class'
Je suis très content de le faire.
Enfin de le refaire, enfin je ne sais plus
Je vous ai posé la question hier sur tous les réseaux sociaux
de ce que vous vouliez pour ce Master Class'
et vous m'avez répondu.
Vous m'avez répondu plein de choses hyper pertinentes, hyper intéressantes
Sachez que je les note toutes dans mon cahier, mon cahier à idées
Elles sont tellement intéressantes et pertinentes qu'il faut que je travaille un peu dessus
dans le sens où il faut que j'écrive un peu les idées
que j'organise, que je vous fasse quelque chose d'assez clair en fait, d'assez pédagogique
et on m'a reparlé du boulier
Vous savez cette semaine j'ai reçu mon nouveau boulier
J'aime les bouliers et les abaques
J'aime bien parce que c'est... c'est un très bon outil en fait
Ça permet de calculer plus rapidement, souvent aussi rapidement que ça
parce que il n'y a pas de..., y'a rien à faire
Et ça a 2 autres avantages
Ça rend les chiffres concrets à l'aide des boules qu'il y a sur les tiges
c'est palpable en fait, c'est de la matière
Et surtout, pour le calcul mental, quand on maîtrise bien le boulier et qu'on a de l'imagination
on peut imaginer un boulier devant soi, on a juste à faire bouger les boules dans sa tête et alors là on a plus qu'à lire le résultat
Dans ce Master Class' n°3, je vais vous apprendre à vous servir d'un boulier chinois
parce qu'il y a aussi le boulier japonais, le boulier russe, y'en a beaucoup de versions
Le boulier chinois, il se compose de 13 tiges et de 2 parties donc la partie supérieure: Les quinaires
On appelle ça les quinaires les billes du haut.
et les billes du bas qu'on appelle les unaires
Cette barre transversale qui les sépare ça va être un petit peu notre ligne de lecture
Tout ce qu'on rapproche de cette barre, c'est ce qu'on va vraiment lire
Ça a été un des premiers systèmes pour calculer, qui a été inventé,
celui ci le boulier chinois il a été inventé en 600 avant JC.
En 600 av. JC vous savez comment on sait que c'est en 600 avant JC ils l'ont calculé
avec un boulier
pas bête
Et là où vous allez voir que c'est hyper simple de s'en servir
et que c'est drôle parce qu'après ça en devient un jeu
Je vous jure après on aime se servir du boulier
Ça devient un jeu en fait, ça devient très ludique de bouger les petites billes comme ça sur... sur les tiges
enfin je crois que... ça peut faire ça peut faire ça à d'autres personnes que moi
J'espère. Ça me rassurerai en fait !
Y a 2 choses à savoir. Je vous disais sur le boulier
Le 1er... la 1ère chose c'est que cette tige là, la 1ère elle correspond aux unités
La 2ème aux dizaines
ensuite aux centaines
aux milliers
aux dizaines de milliers
aux centaines de milliers
aux millions etc..., etc...
C'est la première chose à savoir
C'est pas très dur
La suite, c'est pas plus compliqué
La suite c'est la manière dont on va écrire un chiffre
Si je veux écrire 1, je vais pousser la bille 1 près de ma barre transversale
Ça c'est 1
Et en fait vous allez rien comprendre.
C'était vachement bien tout à l'heure avec la GoPro au dessus de mes mains et tout
Bon vous savez quoi, vous allez plus m'entendre en off
Et moi je vais bouger le système pour vous puissiez bien voir
Alors si, je veux dessiner un chiffre sur mon boulier, on va dire le représenter
Si je veux 1, tout simplement je vais pousser 1 dans ma barre des unités
2 je vais pousser le 2ème, 3 le 3ème, 4 le 4ème et 5 le 5ème
Mais quand j'ai tout mes unaires qui sont montés
alors je peux les remplacer par un quinaire
En descendant une de ses boules là.
Ces boules là, elles valent 5 en fait. Donc à la place de ces 5 là, je vais redescendre une comme ça
Mais pour pas me perdre dans ce que je fais,
tout en descendant ma quinaire je vais redescendre les 5 unaires
Donc là je viens de symboliser 5
donc 6, 7, 8, 9 et 10
et encore une fois j'ai mes 5 unaires de monter donc je redescends une quinaire à la place
Et là, j'ai mes 2 quinaires qui sont mises et oui j'ai 10 dans mes unités
Vous comprenez j'ai 10 juste ici
Donc je vais changer ce 10 là contre le 1 de ma dizaine c'est tout aussi logique
Et tout en la montant ici je vais remonter ces 2 là
Pour ne pas me perdre. Donc je mets mon doigt là et mon doigt là et je monte
La vraie position des doigts sur un abaque c'est comme ça
mais voilà on va juste apprendre comme ça déjà pour commencer
Voilà vous savez tout ce qu'il y a à savoir
Je vais vous apprendre aujourd'hui les additions, les soustractions, les multiplications.
On va pas faire les divisions, les extractions de racine carré pour le moment.
Par contre, si vous voulez qu'on le fasse un jour, ça il y a pas de soucis vous me le dites dans les commentaires et je ferai une vidéo un peu plus poussé sur le boulier
Si ça vous tente mais déjà addition, soustraction et multiplication
Alors une addition on va commencer facile. On va dire 12+37 par exemple
Donc je vais marquer mon 12 ici
et pour ne pas l'oublier je vais marquer le 37 de l'autre côté
donc là 12+37
1, 2, 3 pour le 30 et 5, 6, 7 pour le 7 ça c'est le 37 c'est pour pas oublier ce que je veux calculer
et ça c'est mon 12
donc une dizaine et 2 unités
Les 7 unités qu'il y à ici je vais les ajouter ici
donc je vais le faire lentement
mais là je met 5,
là je me 2
C'était les 7 qu'il y avait là, que je viens de symboliser ici
du coup je les enlève, je les ai calculé
Et les 3 dizaines que j'ai là, je vais les rajouter à la dizaine qui y a là
donc j'inverse et voilà
J'ai donc mon 49
12 et 37 = 49 évidemment
Comme vous avez bien compris le principe, on va faire un peu plus compliqué. Disons...
137 voilà et euh... 145 admettons
145 voilà
J'ai mis mon 145 ici pour pas l'oublier
mon 137 ici
Donc le calcul je vous le fais encore lentement
D'abord mes unités, il faut que je rajoute le 5 ici
donc lui
je vais descendre lui, voilà
je l'ai rajouté là. Là vous voyez j'en ai 2
donc vous vous souvenez de la règle
Je les élimine en en montant un de ce côté en même temps
Ensuite j'ai ces 4 là à rajouter ici
donc un
comme c'est plein, j'inverse
2, 3 et 4
Ça c'est fait. Et 1 que j'ai à rajouter là
juste là. Et ça nous fait 282
137 et 145 font bien 282 évidemment
Allez j'en fait un dernier un petit peu plus rapidement peut être
histoire de bien dire... voilà 257 comme ça, ça nous en met un petit  peu partout
puis on va dire 319 pour en faire un gros aussi
Alors 319 et 257
Donc tout d'abord je vais rajouter ceux là ici, ça nous fait
tac et tac
voilà
ensuite faut que je rajoute celui ci ici donc là c'est pas compliqué
juste je fais ça.
Les 3 ici donc là du coup je l'échange ici
Et ça nous fait 319 + 257= 576
Je vais vite volontairement au lieu de vous faire pleins d'exemples
parce que comme c'est une vidéo de toute manière vous pourrez revenir en arrière, vous pouvez revoir, vous pouvez aussi
tourner la tête comme moi
vous faites ce que vous voulez
C'est ça qui est bien avec les Master Class' en vidéo
Je reviens sur le boulier maintenant pour les soustractions
C'est pas beaucoup plus compliqué
je vais commencé volontairement par une soustraction pas évidente
On va faire 41- 17
comme ça on va être obligé d'enlever 7 de 1
ça va me permettre de vous montrez parce que c'est la seule question qu'on peut se poser quand on fait une soustraction comme ça
donc comment je fais pour enlever ces 7 unités de cette unité là
Et bé, il faut que j'en ai plus ici
il faut que j'en ai beaucoup plus
Du coup, je vais descendre une boule d'ici, pour récupérer ces 2 là
Et là déjà ça devient intéressant parce que là j'ai 11
Et 11 - 7 ça, je sais le faire ça fait 4
donc du coup, je mets mon 4
hop
Et maintenant, il me reste simplement une dizaine à enlever de ces 3 dizaines
Et ça me fait 24
Je crois qu'il y a pas  plus simple que les soustractions avec un boulier
avec encore une fois aucun risque d'erreur
Je commence à avoir mal à la tête à la mettre dans tout les sens
Et on termine avec ce que j'aime le plus faire avec un boulier
C'est mon petit bonbon, c'est ce que j'adore vraiment faire
Ce sont les multiplications
c'est vraiment ludique à faire, moi je m'amuse à en faire pendant que j'ai un truc qui charge sur l'ordi ou des trucs comme ça
Vous allez y prendre gout vraiment
Il faut juste prendre le temps un petit peu d'essayer
Pour info, d'ailleurs, les bouliers y'en a à tout les prix
roh je me mets un petit peu comme ça maintenant
C'est n'importe quoi
Les bouliers il y en a à tout les prix,  y'en a à 5 euros, y'en a à 10 euros, 20 euros et y'en a qui coûte très très cher parce qu'ils sont dans des matériaux spéciaux on va dire
En règle générale, pour 10 euros, 20 euros vous avez un très bon boulier
Je ne sais pas ce qui fait un bon boulier
Le fait que les boules elles glissent sur la tige
Vous pouvez en acheter un vraiment. Je pourrais aussi vous donnez des adresses de sites
Il y a les éditions Mathello qui en font des bouliers
euh... mais vous en trouvez partout de toute manière
j'ai pas de... j'ai rien à vous conseiller
Très franchement un boulier chinois c'est un boulier chinois quoi
On va commencer avec un truc très basique.
On va dire 12 x 12 comme on sait tous que ça fait 144
Donc je met 12 ici, je remet 12 là bas pour pas me perdre,
pour savoir quel est mon multiplicateur
Il y a quelques choses à savoir pour les multiplications
C'est que là ce coup ci on va compter de la gauche vers la droite
toujours de la gauche vers la droite
Je mets mon doigt sur le chiffre qui est le plus à gauche donc là ce sont sur les dizaines
Pour savoir toujours où j'en suis
Et je vais traiter d'abord le 1er chiffre de ce côté là
A savoir les dizaines également
Le résultat que va faire la multiplication entre ces 2 endroits, je vais l'appliquer aux tiges qui précèdent celle où j'ai un doigt
C'est à dire, je m''explique c'est très simple
Là je vais faire 1 x 1
ça fait 1.
Donc je rajoute 1 ici
C'est tout, ça aurait été 2 j'aurais mis 2. 3, 3. 4,4. 5,5
6,6 etc.. ça aurait été 12
et ben j'aurais fait 12 comme ça
le résultat aurait été 38 et ben j'aurai mis 38 comme ça
En fait  j'aurais toujours placer ce résultat avant cette tige.
Je ne touche pas à la tige où j'ai mon doigt
Quand je m'occupe de le multiplier avec le 1er chiffre de l'autre côté
donc 1x1 ça fait 1
Et ensuite je vais multiplier cette tige là (dizaine de droite) avec cette tige là (unités de gauche) et je vais afficher le résultat sur cette tige là (dizaine de droite)
je ne fais surtout pas l'additionner, il ne faut pas l'additionner il faut l'afficher
Donc 2x1 ça fait donc 2
donc ça c'est fait.
Et maintenant mon doigt se décale d'un cran vers la droite
Et je refais la même chose
2x1 ça fait 2
donc je rajoute 2 sur la tige précédente
ici
et maintenant 2x2 ça fait 4
4 que j'affiche sur la tige où j'ai mon doigt
et ça fait bien 144. 12x12 = 144
Est-ce que c'est bien clair?
Je vous en fait un dernier un peu plus rapidement pour la route
On va dire 366 pour la route
J'ai vraiment dire on va en faire un pour la route
366 c'est le nombre de vidéos que je fais cette année c'est pour ça que je mets ça
et on va dire 52
parce que je le fais en 52 semaines
On va multiplier 366 par 52
366 c'est ici (à droite) et 52 c'est là (à gauche)
Donc je met mon d'abord sur les chiffres qui sont toujours à gauche
3x5 ça fait 15
Donc je met mon 15 comme cela
avant la tige
ensuite 3x2 ça fait 6
donc je dessine mon 6 ici
J'arrive là ça nous fait 6
6x5 ça fait 30 donc je fais 1, 2, 3 et 0 là
et 6x2 ça fait 12
1 pour le 10 de 12 et 2 ici pour le 12
j'affiche le chiffre des unités ici
et je passe à ce doigt là
Ici 6x5 30 donc 1, 2, 3 je rajoute pour le 30
et là vous avez vu j'ai une conversion à faire
je descend là, mais là j'en ai encore une à faire
je remonte là
et je termine par mon 6x2 qui nous font 12, donc une dizaine, et le 2 de 12
et voilà ça nous fait le résultat de 19032
et 53x366 ça fait bien 19032
Bon j'aurai quand même eu le courage de la refaire. Enfin le courage, on va plutôt dire la motivation de refaire cette vidéo sur le boulier
De toute manière c'est un truc qui me passionne donc vraiment ça me dérange pas de l'expliquer
Si vous avez des questions, vous me demandez, il y a pas de soucis on peut en reparler
J'ai volontairement pas fait un Master Class' trop long
parce que je me dis que là
avoir pleins d'exemple ça sert à rien
C'est tout l'intérêt d'avoir ces vidéos, d'avoir ce MentalVlog c'est que vous pouvez faire pause, revenir en arrière
essayer de le faire, de le refaire indéfiniment
J'ai pas besoin de vous donner trop exemples je crois
Vraiment utiliser un boulier *avec accent québécois* vous allez adorer ça
Je sais pas pourquoi je prend cette accent
Cette nuit, on a passé les 1500 abonnés. C'est énorme
1500 abonnés
Je vous ai annoncé un objectif, c'est qu'à 2500 abonnés
on va se faire une rencontre ensemble en live sur internet
c'est à dire on va faire un live de 2h, d'au moins de 2h
je dis 2h mais je sais même pas si on s'arrêtera au bout de 2h
on fera un vrai live ensemble
Chacun chez soi, on va pouvoir se voir, on va pouvoir s'écrire, se parler, faire pleins de trucs
à 2500 abonnés
Voilà c'est mon objectif
c'est mon but; c'est le cran que je dois dépasser
ah ben je suis tout petit hein
Et vous pouvez m'aider à dépasser ce cran là. C'est à dire vous pouvez partager ces vidéos si elles vous plaisent
Si il y a des vidéos qui vous plaisent, d'autres qui vous font rire, d'autres qui vous s'intéresse vous pouvez les partager
Quand je dis partager c'est pas que sur internet, vous pouvez vraiment parler aux gens autour de vous en fait
dans votre quotidien
ceux que vous connaissez, ceux que ça pourrait aider
ceux que ça pourrait simplement intéresser
Partagez ces vidéos
Parlez en
Soyons 2500, faisons cette apéro ensemble virtuellement chacun de notre côté de caméra
Bref abonnez vous à la chaîne
et rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!